alors tu habites non seulement les
femmes qui qui vont s'habiller dans tes
boutiques mais tu habites aussi des
stars quels sont les stars que tu as mis
non
bonsoir alors toujours entouré de très
jolie femme habillé avec ta collection
était 88 est-ce que tu peux nous dire
dans quel esprit tu as dessiné cette
collection je suis resté un peu sur
l'idée que il faut quand même décliner
la femme moderne et on peut pas la faire
sauter à travers beaucoup
d'escravagances je suis pas partisan de
ça je pense que la femme moderne assez
de personnalités pour aimer de
s'habiller avant tout pour soi-même
après pour les autres et pas pour jouer
un rôle un peu trop personnage de
spectacle alors finalement Nino c'est un
diminutif un petit peu ça veut dire
petit puis il y a la maman de Nino qui
est à biélor qui de temps en temps et
pas très gentil avec toi qui t'engueule
quand tu fais des choses qui sont pas
bien été à la tête d'un groupe énorme
c'était dans combien de pays aujourd'hui
je suis dans tous les pays on peut être
en tant que livre commerce j'ajoute que
Nino c'est aussi tout ce qu'on a fait
sur beaucoup de restaurants italiens
là le mien vient de la diminution de
Antoine c'est Antonin ça fait partie du
côté un peu ça c'est toujours sur le
pseudo se donner un peu une allure
gentille j'en ai un peu plus depuis 50
ans c'est énorme mais pas énorme disons
que c'est assez grand et j'espère que ça
devient plus grand que tu regrette pas
un peu les peuples ou finalement tu
étais un peu comme ça Dolce Vita appeler
Boy ou tu avais encore plus de jolies
femmes autour de toi ou tu passais
beaucoup plus de temps dans les boîtes
de nuit non peut-être j'en avais moins
comme nombre mais ils étaient plus
proches peut-être éventuellement mais
évidemment on reste toujours certaines
choses confortable mais je crois que la
vie est faite toujours d'une succession
de Paris dans lequel on laisse toujours
un peu une plage confortable pour savoir
purée l'aventure est fascinante on
trouve de nouvelles dimensions après on
regrette un peu on imagine le moment
confortable tout était beaucoup plus
doux et facile mais finalement tout cela
ça fait partie du charme de cette
merveilleuse aventure qui est la vie il
faut le vivre alors tu lances un parfum
pour femme qui s'appelle Nino chaoti
pour femme tout simplement un parfum
pour l'âme quelle est l'implication de
quelqu'un comme toi dans un tel parfum
est-ce que c'est un jour des gens qui
disent voilà le parfum qu'on a inventé
pour vous puis vous mettez votre nom
dessus ou est-ce que tu interviens dans
les dans la fabrication et dans le dans
l'image du parfum quel est l'implication
je crois que j'ai suivi la procédure
habituelle citrique aspire dans mon
travail parce que tout ce qui porte dans
le Nord j'aime bien de le voir à fond et
le vivre à fond c'est d'ailleurs ce qui
m'est fascine de cette métier c'est que
dans n'importe quel ce qu'on fait il
faut exprimer quand même une idée une
image une certaine idéale quand même et
c'est évident qu'avec un parfum femme
tout cela ça a été un peu le maximum de
tout cela je considère presque que cette
parfum femme qui forme un homme
maintenant c'est une des meilleures
choses que je fais parce que on irait
tout tellement dedans soit du point de
vue de l'aspect extérieur des lignes du
flaconnage que du jeu lui-même tout ce
qui me fascine m'intéresse d'une femme
et qui était toujours un peu de moteur
qui m'a amené dans cette vie et à vivre
dans ce monde de la mode alors tu
habites non seulement les femmes qui qui
vont côté boutique mais tu habites aussi
des stars quels sont les stars que tu
avais en particulier il y en a une que
depuis trois ans vraiment je vis un peu
avec elle en tant que sa façon de
s'habiller que ces 4 litres mais j'adore
les Italiens quand ils parlent anglais
et quels sont les stars du passé enfin
des stars qui sont décédés aujourd'hui
d'Hollywood ou de la grande époque que
tu as aimé habillé
une certaine ombre je peux dire que pour
les hommes j'ai fait le dernier pantalon
sur mesure pour que votre channel
présent
on peut la considérer stars
j'avais marre l'industrie à la boutique
elle n'est pas qu'elle était venue
acheter des chapeaux j'avais fait tous
les chapeaux de harceau
mais il faut te dire quoi même deux
héroïnes qui sont évidemment de
personnages qui ne sortent très proches
et Catherine pour avoir une déco ça
c'est ton style de femme absolument ça
c'est ça
tout le monde dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui c'est les nouveaux contes de
tiers
je suis ravi que le flamenco soit en
train de planter le rock n' roll je suis
ravi que les Italiens dans les affaires
soient en train de tailler des paupières
aux Anglo-Saxons alors tu finalement tu
attribues ça quoi ce ce Renaissance
finalement de l'Italie je crois que en
tout cas je sais pas si chez les
Italiens c'est mieux qu'ailleurs mais
seulement chez les Italiens il y a comme
un iseptaine fantaisie à une certaine
amour pour l'aventure que ça ça les
pousse un peu à essayer à oser à tenter
et à prendre les choses avec peut-être
un peu plus de décontraction et avant
tout une autre grande qualité je crois
il se prend un peu moins au sérieux et
ça aide beaucoup à être sérieux
à seulement je crois que oui je crois
que oui un Italie ça fait 20 siècles
qu'on est habitué à avoir du recul
devant la vie tu es content d'être là à
seulement tu viens au bain douche de
temps en temps
non franchement non
j'avoue que je sens plus du tout dans
les boîtes parce que c'était merveilleux
le temps où je pourrais derrière des
filles et tout rentrer dans une boîte
pour boire un verre et regarder c'est
légèrement
oui mais je peux faire garder mes
souvenirs
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu